in the tablet wireframes when a list
item is selected it shows this blue
activated state background this can be
done by setting the background of the
list item to be a state drawable we can
look at the documentation for the
stateless drawable which is linked below
essentially a stateless drawable allows
you to specify different drawables based
on the state of the view we provide you
the code for the stateless drawable drop
it in by creating a drawable folder
under the res directory when set as the
background of a list item we see that
the background is just transparent by
default such as this today layout here
when the view is pressed then we see a
gray background when the view is
activated then we see this blue color
this is also indicating that it's the
selected item in the two pane mode we
also have a second version of the touch
selector file for lollipop devices and
above this is saved in the drawable v21
folder set on platforms API level 21 and
above it will use this version of the
touch selector on older advices it will
fall back to the touch selector in the
base drawable folder one of the main
principles of material design is
responsive interaction one way to
accomplish this is that when a user
touches the device the device will
acknowledge the interaction and a ripple
will radiate out from the touch point
this is done with a ripple drawable you
can add a ripple element in your
stateless drawable XML for the V 21
touch selector it's the same except that
for the press state we have a ripple
drawable with a gray color for touch
feedback and on a lollipop device you
can see the ripple in the list item
layout we set the background to be this
touch selector we do the same for the
list item forecast today layout back in
the touch selector file I want to note
that there are some colors here the at
Android color notation is for a
framework defined color the other colors
are ones that we defined in the colors
dot XML file this file is located in the
values folder of your app it's useful to
store colors in a central location if
you need a reference colors multiple
times in your app as a hint to make a
list item show its activated state you
can look at the documentation for the
XML attribute choice mode for the
ListView once you find the right
attribute you'll realize that you want a
different behavior for one pane versus
two pane mode well you could change the
behavior
programmatically in the Java code we'd
like you to do it purely via the
resource XML files using a style read
the stock to learn about how Styles can
be defined in XML and use what you
learned earlier about defining
alternative resources for different
sized devices in general styles are a
way that you can group together
attributes for a view for example these
text attributes are replaced by this
style code font the code font style is
defined in the styles that XML file
located in the values folder you can
also have styles inherit other styles by
specifying the parent there are a couple
of other examples you can check out on
this page this is what the app should
look like when you're done in one pane
mode we don't see the activated state
but there's still the regular press
state with the ripple and then it goes
away